You know, it start raining.
And it can get really tricky for sure.
Like it can get really, really tricky.
And sometimes I need to go rescue people
because they get stuck
then they start kind of backing up
and then they go out over the edge.
I don't see anyone yet.
It’s just dumping rain,
which is now going to impact the road
and how the guests get here.
At my restaurant
the biggest challenge for the guests
coming, is really traffic.
Not actually
if a road is going to be stable enough
to get a car to my restaurant.
But then Rolando tells me
they're not actually coming in a car.
I ordered some military bus
that they use to go to the top
of the volcano
Yeah.
Rolando seems to be just fine.
He's laughing about it, saying, “Ah
it'll be fine.
We'll just put 30 people in a party bus.
We'll truck them up this hill”.
He seems to be going with the flow
in more ways than one here.
If he's not worried, I'm
going to try not to be worried.
Oh, now they're coming?
Down the hill.
Uh-oh.
We may get some grumpy faces...
So I think that's good.
Are they walking?
Ah walking.
Ah [bleep]
and they’re like in nice clothes.
Yes, this restaurant is remote
and getting there is half the adventure.
But Charlie Collins is a very important
chef, and trekking through the mud
for this meal isn't the best way
to create a first impression.